première rencontre de haut rang entre la
chine et les états unis depuis mars
dernier trois jours après avoir dévoilé
sa nouvelle stratégie commerciale face à
pékin des émissaires américains ont
rencontré hier à zurich des
représentants chinois une rencontre
alors que les positions se durcissent
entre les deux puissances sur le
commerce aussi bien que sur taïwan dubaï
des vikings ont prévu de s'entretenir
virtuellement avant la fin de l'année
elle les détails avec notre
correspondant l'architecte naval
washington poursuit sa séquence
diplomatique avec pékin à zurich le
conseiller à la sécurité nationale de la
maison blanche jay sullivan a rencontré
le plus haut responsable du parti
communiste chinois en charge des
affaires étrangères une rencontre a
présenté par la maison blanche comme la
continuité de l'échangé téléphonique qui
a eu lieu le 9 septembre dernier entre
joe biden et le président chinois xi
jingping alors le communiqué qui a été
publié à l'issue de cet échange qui a eu
lieu en suisse est assez laconique la
maison blanche affirme avoir exposé à
pékin les points de divergence entre les
deux pays mais aussi je cite l'intérêt à
travailler conjointement sur des
dossiers transnationaux il y a deux
sujets qui fâchent particulièrement en
ce moment entre pékin et washington
d'abord la question de taiwan puisque la
maison blanche a exprimé en début de
semaine ses inquiétudes concernant des
vols effectués par l'armée chinoise dans
la région et puis il ya évidemment la
question des relations commerciales
entre les deux pays on sait que la
représentante américaine chargée du
commerce va rencontrer ses homologues
chinois cette semaine justement pour
évoquer le respect de l'accord signé
entre pékin et washington en 2020 et
puis la maison blanche indique aussi que
suite à cet entretien entre jake
sullivan et les représentants chinois et
bien le conseiller à la sécurité
nationale américaine va aussi rencontrer
des responsables européens l'idée selon
la maison blanche l'encore et de
réaffirmer l'importance des relations
transatlantiques on sait que notamment
sur la question du positionnement à
adopter vis-à-vis de la chine il y à de
grandes divergences entre certains pays
de l'union européenne et les etats unis